[Música]
les doy la bienvenida a un nuevo
episodio de boleto de vuelta que en esta
ocasión nos lleva a la filadelfia de los
años 70 y 80 cuando fue escenario de una
parte o una serie del grupo
revolucionario en move que abogaba por
un regreso a la naturaleza el derecho de
los animales y el fin del capitalismo
fue liderado por jon áfrica un
afroamericano que adoptó el nombre de
áfrica para hacer referencia al
continente que consideraba como el
origen del mundo al igual que todos los
miembros de move adoptaron ese mismo
nombre en esa época todos vivían bajo el
mismo techo en el oeste de filadelfia
eran activistas protestaban delante de
los zoológicos e instituciones políticas
a las que se oponían fueron vigilados de
cerca por las autoridades con las cuales
tuvieron varios enfrentamientos hasta la
fatídica jornada del 13 de mayo de 1985
ese día la policía lanzó una bomba sobre
la casa del move para desalojar a sus
habitantes de esta manera la ciudad
bombardeo a sus propios ciudadanos 11
personas murieron una historia en la
cual ninguno de los responsables
compareció ante la justicia más de
treinta años después france24 regresó a
filadelfia para hablar con sus
protagonistas
de ese oscuro capítulo
esta mañana a las 5 30 los miembros del
mover recibieron una orden de desalojo
veinte minutos después escuchamos tiros
todo el mundo se lanzaba hacia adentro
las órdenes resonaban por todas partes
durante los primeros veinte minutos fue
un caos completo los locales están
entrando en pánico salieron corriendo
los policías están en posición para
disparar
[Aplausos]
la artillería que utilizaron era una
artillería de guerra
estaba dirigida contra nosotros aunque
no hubiésemos cometido ningún crimen
la policía disparó tantas balas que
tuvieron que ir a reabastecerse al otro
lado de la ciudad
tenemos nuevas imágenes del episodio que
aparentemente le puso fin al move en
esta noche el lanzamiento de un
explosivo a las 5 27 de la tarde un
helicóptero de la policía
me dirigía a la casa de un amigo cuando
lo vi caminar hacia mí y decirme le
lanzaron una bomba al móvil y mi primera
reacción fue de incredulidad le contesté
no no es cierto
todo el barrio parecía una zona de
guerra era terrible
cuando atacaron a nuestra familia el 13
de mayo tenían previsto lanzar esa bomba
y lo hicieron de tal manera que la casa
quedará reducida a cenizas porque no
querían que quedara ningún sobreviviente
es uno de esos días que no dan ganas de
revivir y que uno espera que no vuelvan
a ocurrir nunca más eso fue lo que
sentimos todos
creo que los bomberos no intervinieron
por las mismas razones por las cuales
los policías no dejaron de disparar el
comisario quería matar a todas las
personas que estaban adentro
bueno el sitio de vivar y enero
durante los años 70 la organización move
dio mucho de qué hablar a causa de sus
posturas revolucionarias
fundada por un líder llamado john áfrica
el movimiento defendía una ideología
antisistema basada en los derechos
igualitarios de todos los seres vivos la
ecología la vida en comunidad y la lucha
contra las violencias policiales mike
áfrica juniors es un hijo del move nació
hace 42 años
detrás de estos barrotes
estamos en la correccional de filadelfia
en la cárcel donde nací
mi madre estaba embarazada
porque la policía y demora sal con
nuestra casa
waters
mis padres antes de meterlos en la
cárcel a cristian
restringidas delgado
volvió aquí por primera vez hace tres
años y me pareció un lugar familiar
aunque ni siquiera recuerde haber
visitado a mi madre aquí
el 8 de agosto de 1978 la policía de
filadelfia trató de desalojar por
primera vez a los miembros del móvil
bajo la orden del alcalde de la época en
ese entonces la casa estaba habitada por
una decena de personas que se negaban a
obedecer hubo fuego cruzado
y un oficial de policía murió al recibir
un disparo en la nuca
su muerte condujo al juicio de nueve
miembros del move acusados de haber sido
los primeros en disparar entre ellos
estaban los padres de michael junior
como medio de policía incluso hoy en día
nadie lo sabe muchos creen que fueron
las personas del 9 muchos piensan que se
trató de fuego amigo no lo sé pero lo
que sí sé es que mis padres pasaron 40
años en la cárcel por un crimen que no
cometieron los nueve fueron condenados a
cumplir penas entre 30 y 100 años de
cárcel por asesinato en tercer grado
sin embargo proclamaron ser inocentes
finalmente los padres de mike fueron
liberados en 2018 tras una vida de lucha
judicial
yo luché por sacar a mis padres de la
cárcel después de la adolescencia
durante al menos 25 o 27 años
nunca me rendí pensaba que mientras
ellos estuvieran vivos al igual que yo
debía tratar de ayudarles
a cada equipo entran al aire
esta condena condujo al move a provocar
otro enfrentamiento unos años después en
1981 la organización se instaló a unos
kilómetros de su antiguo barrio aquí en
el oeste de filadelfia donde el
vecindario es en su mayoría
afroamericano link washington es
periodista siguió al move desde su
creación y recuerda la época en la que
el movimiento protestaba día y noche
desde esta casa
pensaban que presionando a sus vecinos
estos no tendrían otra opción más que
exigirle la liberación de sus nueve
camaradas a los representantes de la
ciudad
instalaron unos altavoces encima de la
casa para asediar a los vecinos a
cualquier hora del día
en navidad de 1994 arengaron al barrio
durante 24 horas sin parar
dave irwin football world awards
[Música]
y como el move hacía esto había una
presencia mediática y policial
permanente lo que también molestaba a
los vecinos había caos en todo el barrio
esta situación duró meses y se volvió
insostenible para los habitantes de la
avenida osas en varias ocasiones los
vecinos trataron de alertar a las
autoridades de la ciudad pero no
obtuvieron ninguna reacción en nuestras
instituciones que pagamos con nuestros
impuestos no son capaces de garantizar y
proteger nuestros derechos como
ciudadanos actuaremos por nuestra cuenta
en la madrugada del 13 de mayo de 1985
wilson wood primer alcalde afroamericano
de filadelfia ordenó el despliegue de
500 policías para desalojar al mover
había 13 personas en el interior de la
casa tomada por asalto entre ellas había
seis niños después de horas de tiros de
intimidaciones la policía le lanzó una
bomba a la organización el edificio se
prendió de inmediato en llamas
rápidamente el fuego se propagó por toda
la calle y más de 60 casas quedaron
reducidas a cenizas si hay personas que
se encuentren así que estén cerca es
evidente que nadie sobrevivirá a la
explosión todos los miembros del móvil
fueron quemados vivos excepto un niño y
una mujer ramona áfrica única
sobreviviente aún con vida hoy en día a
sus 71 años enferma sigue viviendo en
filadelfia con otros miembros de la
familia áfrica nos reunimos con ella
junto con janine y janeth áfrica quienes
estaban en la cárcel cuando ocurrió el
bombardeo ambas perdieron un hijo en
medio del drama
cuando nos dimos cuenta de que la casa
estaba en llamas tratamos de salir
pero había policías por todas partes
detrás de la casa y nos dispararon para
impedir que saliéramos
por eso murieron 11 personas y solo dos
de nosotros pudimos sobrevivir
sabe cómo supimos que nuestra familia
había sido asesinada
en ese momento estábamos en la cárcel en
una unidad restringida aisladas
los oficiales a cargo de la cárcel
habrían una por una a las puertas de
nuestras celdas para decirnos
tu hijo murió y las volvían a cerrar
ningún representante de la ciudad nos
contactó para avisarnos que había
ocurrido un bombardeo
que nuestros hijos habían sido
asesinados y para preguntarnos que
queríamos hacer con sus cuerpos nada
hasta el día de hoy todavía declaró a
donde enviaron los restos de mi hijo o
qué hicieron con él
apenas se recuperó de sus quemaduras
ramona fue encarcelada durante siete
años por incitación a los disturbios y
conspiración en 1996 la ciudad de
filadelfia la indemnizó por 500 mil
dólares por sufrimiento y heridas pero a
pesar de dos investigaciones de un gran
jurado y de un proceso judicial nadie
fue acusado
no detuvieron a nadie ningún policía
ningún oficial
nadie fue hecho responsable ni acusado
de haber asesinado a nuestra familia
y creanme fue un asesinato no fue un
accidente
después descubrimos que los bomberos
habían recibido la orden de no apagar el
incendio aunque nadie les estuviera
disparando como trataron de acercar y
recibieron la orden de no hacer nada
treinta y seis años después la policía
de filadelfia sigue negando esta versión
en esta oficina de oficiales retirados
todos recuerdan el move en la pared está
colgado el retrato de su camarada que
murió en 1978 durante el primer
enfrentamiento
charly expósito es el presidente de la
asociación el 13 de mayo del 85 estaba
prestando servicio y afirma que los
miembros del móvil estaban armados
créame le estaban disparando a los
bomberos no tengo razón para
cuánto tiempo ha pasado 35 años güey
porque yo diría la unicén y the walt
tendría sentido negarlo
le aseguro que le disparaban
crecían los bomberos trataban de
acercarse para apagarlo pero recibían
disparos así que su jefe decidió
enviarlos
aún así era necesario lanzarle una bomba
a los ciudadanos no fue una respuesta
completamente desproporcionada el
oficial retirado duda
personalmente tal vez lo habría pensado
dos veces antes de tomar esa decisión
pero
pero cuando empezaron a disparar todo
cambio la presencia de los niños
seguramente me habría impedido tomar esa
decisión
pero no digo que se hayan equivocado la
situación se estaba volviendo realmente
inmanejable
las personas recibían disparos no podían
esperar era necesario actuar
en mi opinión las personas del move
tuvieron la culpa desde el comienzo por
lo que hicieron en el barrio
es difícil imaginar hoy en día lo que
pasó en la avenida osas al final de la
calle una placa discreta recuerda el
drama tyri johnson es una de las
memorias del barrio vivía aquí en 1985 y
vio como todo se prendió en llamas
si todas las casas de esquina hasta
abajo
la única que quedó intacta
todo el barrio sufrió
a partir del 61 las casas quemadas
fueron reconstruidas por la ciudad pero
permanecieron vacías durante casi 15
años para tyri el move quería un
enfrentamiento pero las primeras
víctimas del drama fueron los vecinos
los vecinos se sintieron culpables por
lo que pasó
pero lo único que hicieron fue quejarse
de repente había varios niños muertos y
sus vidas habían sido destruidas
un barrio quedó reducido a polvo porque
la ciudad no supo manejar la situación
y hoy en día que pasa han pasado 35 años
y se sigue hablando del móvil los
periodos
[Música]
es un problema que no desaparece sí no
hoy en día la organización move sigue
existiendo y vive en particular a través
de mike áfrica junior desde su estudio
en el norte de filadelfia cada semana
graba un podcast sobre un tema distinto
el move existe para perturbar al sistema
y provocar un cambio revolucionario en
palabras de jon áfrica el poder de la
verdad es definitivo es importante
contarle la historia del mover a las
personas para recordarles que eso pasó y
tratar de que no se repita es necesario
que se implementen medidas para que la
policía no pueda simplemente lanzarle
una bomba a unos individuos es necesario
que haya leyes y asegurar que la policía
las respete y si no lo hace entonces hay
que suprimir la inmunidad calificada que
los protege de los procesos
asistenciales civiles debemos avanzar
paso a paso pero el camino es largo
criado por las demás mujeres de la
organización cuando era un niño
mike encarna la siguiente generación la
que ahora lucha por hacer que se escuche
la voz de los afroamericanos y por la de
sus derechos
nunca obtuvimos justicia nunca
no sólo porque somos integrantes del
móvil
sino porque al ser negra o blanca hemos
obtenido justicia por parte de este
sistema
y es posible decir que las personas del
molde estaban locas o encontrar todas
las razones peyorativas que siquiera
en el derby javier drive
pero nada justifica lanzarle una bomba a
unos individuos
filadelfia cuna de la independencia de
eeuu y ciudad símbolo de las libertades
estadounidenses bombardeo a sus propios
ciudadanos el 13 de mayo de 1985 en 2020
la ciudad se disculpó formalmente ante
los miembros del move pero esta historia
aún se sigue pasando por alto
llegamos al final de este episodio de
boleto de vuelta a filadelfia recuerde
que si quiere ver este y otros
contenidos en español puede visitar
nuestra página web france24 puntocom
hasta pronto